Pokemon Go is life…at least for the millions
of players who've swarmed the mobile game
since its launch.
While developer Niantic plans on making the
game more robust, balanced, and stable, much
of the game hasn’t met players’ high expectations.
Easy prey
One of the most important parts of Pokemon
is the ability to battle wild Pokemon.
While Pokemon Go allows users to wander around
and go find a Gastly, there's really no fighting
involved.
Instead, capturing wild pocket monsters has
become a game of ring toss.
By bouncing a Pokeball off of a circle surrounding
your prey, you can attempt a capture.
It's like an abridged version of a real Pokemon
experience.
Rural ruminations
Pokemon Go is catered to players in populated
and tech-savvy areas.
Because it’s essentially a reskin of Niantic's
previous game, Ingress, every Pokestop is
a place which Ingress players had previously
marked.
If you live in a small town, your local game
probably won’t have many stops.
None of this really fits Pokemon, where trainers
spend most of their time in forests, with
an occasional visit to a small town or a gym.
Granted, wandering through the Wi-Fi-less
woods to play a mobile game isn't really safe,
but for now, Pokemon Go remains a game optimized
for cityfolk.
Terrible tech
If your phone isn’t the newest model, or
it's slightly cloudy, or you're stuck on an
overloaded server, Go’s location services
have been shady.
Players have spent days on end waiting for
their game to maintain a consistent connection.
Even worse?
You finally find a distant Pokestop and you
inexplicably lose your GPS signal.
It's enough to make you want to stomp an Oddish…and
those guys are adorable.
Pay-to-play
Because Go is a mobile app, microtransactions
are expected.
But because it's an actively competitive mobile
app, those with cash can quickly rise to the
top.
Wallet warriors are an issue with just about
every multiplayer online game made for smart
phones, but Pokemon is a property that's basically
intended for kids.
Putting a paywall in front of a little aspiring
Ash Ketchum just feels nasty.
Lousy launch
Niantic's servers just can’t handle the
app’s traffic.
Games sometimes freeze immediately after important
captures...if you can log on at all.
While portions of the app have smoothed out,
there are still plenty of aspects that simply
don't work consistently enough to offer a
truly enjoyable experience.
Everything still feels like it's in beta mode,
but the future still looks exciting.
Hackemon
As with any competitive app, there are already
cheaters out there.
Within days of release, it was easy to find
files helping players obtain endless currency,
level up their Pokemon without any effort,
and visit local gyms without ever leaving
their bathroom.
One would hope that the moral lessons of Pokemon
would somehow carry over into real-world Pokemon
Go etiquette, but as long as there are people
who can't be trusted, there'll always disappointment
and distrust.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what’s
disappointed you in Pokemon Go...